Deadpool one of them first of all not
just a massive success there are movies
that are a huge global success that
movies also fantastic it's hilarious
yeah that's great and you were fantastic
yeah very much it was really fun you
enjoy doing I did I mean - the two days
of sex scenes it was wonderful
the whole experience that's right it so
you have a there's a part of Deadpool
where you and Ryan Reynolds are having a
passionate scene together and it goes on
and on and on
I've watched it on a loop what I woke up
- and how you said that took two days
it's a I think about two days to shoot
because it was us making sweet love for
an entire calendar year mm-hmm so is all
the holidays you know like we dressed
differently for everyone and believe me
there's a lot left on the cutting-room
floor because there's a lot of holidays
yes and I feel good about that the part
that was left out oh did they take a
part out to upset you no no I mean I
literally mean there's that's enough sex
oh yeah like nobody needs to see more
than that then and what was in the movie
no no see it was very you know what it
was it was very hard to do it was very
erotic but it was funny at the same time
it has really good jokes in there and
for my money it's the second best love
scene that Ryan Reynolds has ever done
well thank you yeah wait wait wait
what's the first though let's take a
look
[Applause]
you wasn't over still is
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow my question is did he ever play with
your ear I with Hasani shot that you
know he he improvised that he starts
doing that to my ear and I'm thinking
how was that erotic in any way anything
he does is erotic yeah that's true
you know what I will say this that my
white when my wife saw that and she
loves Ryan Reynolds and she saw that
into her I said would you think and she
said it ruined both of you it's not
often I get to say to a TV hosts that
we've shared the same man no no no no no
no I'm very proud
you